they're afraid they would be judged I
would say you know don't even think
about that you know just be true to
yourself because are you really even
like it's what's the point in being on
this earth if you're gonna try to be
someone you're not
that's Dwayne Wade's child Ziya speaking
her truth the former NBA star dropped by
Ellen on Tuesday and opened up about
supporting his twelve-year-old who
identifies as parts of the lgbtq+
community I'll say probably we are proud
parents of a child in the lgbtq+
community and we're proud allies as well
and we take our roles and our
responsibility as parents very seriously
afterward his wife Gabrielle Union
posted a video on Instagram showing via
offering advice to others who may be
going through a similar situation even
when people are being mean even when
when people are getting hurt but because
they're trying to be themselves and even
even do that you still want people to
make sure that they live their truth
yeah I think and I know they can get
tough definitely but I think you push
through and you be the best you it's
worth it I feel like it's very worth it
when you reach that point of like
yourself
Ziya had this final message for
followers you could look in the mirror
and like say like hi to yourself like
mmm nice to meet you
instead of like Gabrielle captioned the
video quotes meet saya
she's compassionate loving whip-smart
and we are so proud of her it's okay to
listen to love and respect your children
exactly as they are love and light good
people celebrities immediately started
showing their support
as Natalie Portman responded with a
bunch of heart emojis while Katie Couric
wrote quote beautiful thank you for your
words of wisdom Zaya
Grey's Anatomy star Ellen Pompeo
commented quote so important so
impactful so many kids will be inspired
by her and her truth and Reese
Witherspoon had this message for Dwayne
and gabrielle quote I loved
what incredible parents you are our
child comes home with a question when a
child comes home with the issue when a
child comes home with anything it's odd
job as parents to listen to that to give
them the best information that we can
the best feedback that we can and that
doesn't change because sexuality is now
involved in it during his appearance on
ellen dwayne opened up about the moment
saya who was originally assigned male at
birth and was named zion shared that she
wanted to be referred to with female
pronouns twelve year old came home first
died and everybody I don't know what
everyone knows originally named Zion
Zion born as a boy came home and said
hey so I want to talk to you guys you
know I think going for it I'm ready to
live my truth and I want to be a
reference that she and her I would love
for you guys to call me Ziya and so
internally now is our job to one go out
and get information to reach out to
every relationship that we have and the
38 year old had this to say about what
it means to support his kids when Zion
came home and said hey you called me
saya and I'm ready to take on this I
looked at and said you are a leader you
are a leader and it's the opportunity to
allow you to be a voice right now as to
us because she's 12 years old but
eventually it would be to her
[Music]